Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
new house of the dragon video for aegon's Conquest
you probably heard the news they announced they do
have plans to do a show based on aegon's conquest
and other moments in the targaryen's history so
I'll explain how that's going to work and how
they're going to do it through the house of
the dragon show if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos of
course I'll be doing videos for all this we'll
probably be doing house the dragon and other Game
of Thrones spin-offs and prequels till we're like
100 years old it'll be fantastic I can't wait
to talk about house the Dragon A Song of Ice
and Fire Game of Thrones when I'm 100 years
old during the current episodes on House of
the Dragon they've actually recontextualized a
lot of the lore around aegon's Conquest why it
happened what he did during the conquest and how
that connects with what was happening during the
events of Game of Thrones later in the timeline
one of the reasons why it seems like they're
retconning things is because George RR Martin who
helped them develop House of the Dragon like he's
helping them write episodes so that most of
the Fire and Blood book that we're actually
adapting for the events of House of the Dragon
was written by maesters of the third parties
who just weren't privy to all the information in
the way that viserys explained it to rhaenyra it
was a secret that was passed down from King to
successor and eventually it was lost so that's
why during the events of the main series The
Only Way the characters start learning about
it is through these ancient texts that were
thought lost inside the Citadel from my blood
come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song Ice and Fire
it also sounds like that's how rhaegar learned
about the prophecy later too before he died is
that he found it by combing through the Citadel
so quick history the aegon who conquered the Seven
Kingdoms was first of his name aegon Targaryen he
had a couple main nicknames that the realm later
gave him the Conqueror for obvious reasons in
the dragon so anytime on the show or during the
events of Game of Thrones when you hear people
refer to themselves or to other targaryens as
the dragon like oh you seem like the dragon today
they're likening them to aegon the Conqueror the
way that later members of their family in the
realm viewed him is sort of like a superstar so
as you'd expect over like the 300 plus years after
his Conquest in their history ruling over Westeros
up to the events of the main show ending with Jon
Snow many many members of their family were named
aegon for instance on the show right now we have
aegon II they call him second of his name if Jon
Snow had actually sat on the Iron Throne he would
have been called aegon vi aegon v is actually the
younger brother of maester Aemon and here's where
we start with the conquest they're like some
important backstory aegon the Conqueror was born
on Dragonstone many years after the targaryens
had fled ancient valyria and the Doom it happened
they had taken five dragons with them when they
sailed for Dragonstone but only three survived
to the time of aegon. Balerion the black dread
who's already died before the events of House of
the dragon and the two dragons that his sisters
eventually rode vhagar who we just saw on the
show written by Laena Velaryon in meraxes who
was written by his other sister rhaenys on House
of the Dragon princess rhaenys the queen Who Never
Was is named after aegon's sister rhaenys during
House of the Dragon we've recently learned from
viserys that aegon was born with the ability
to dragon dream just like he was and now we've
learned that Helaena Targaryen has his daughter
with Alicent the last ring has no legs at all
you will have a dragon one day he'll have to close
an eye those are Dragon dreams that she's reciting
they're about two different members of their
family the one where she says the last ring will
have no legs is about aegon the second I don't
want to explain exactly what it means because
it's kind of a spoiler and I think that they're
going to pay it off in a future season the other
one is about Aemond Targaryen and when she says
he'll have to close an eye that's all about him
claiming a dragon like he'll claim a dragon but
he has to close an eye to do it and they're going
to pay that off in episode 7 I believe so I don't
want to talk too much about that because it's kind
of a spoiler right now dragon dreams are basically
the gift of Prophecy visions of the future that
are specific to the Targaryen family or people
of Valyrian descent Daenerys Targaryen also has
a version of dragon dreams on the main show in
the house of the undying seeing visions of her
future but not totally understanding what they
mean at the time and even though people mostly
think about the conquest when they think about
aegon that wasn't the first war that he actually
fought in on the house of the Dragon Show recently
in this past episode they actually referenced the
century of blood and that was about the hundred
years after the Doom of valyria where everyone
in essos was fighting over the territory that was
left in the wake of the Doom aegon the Conqueror
used Baler in the black dread to Aid pentos list
some of these other cities in the East over here
which is what the prince from the East here was
talking to Damon about your ancestor aegon the
Conqueror aided us in the century of blood won't
you do it again now in present day so that took
place way before the actual war of Conquest but at
some point when this was happening aegon Targaryen
eventually had the dragon dream about the long
night and someone from his bloodline eventually
stopping it he called it A Song of Ice and Fire
which is the title of George RR Martin's main
novel series and he had the prophecy etched on the
Valyrian dagger which he had come into possession
of using Valyrian pyromancers they're kind of
like the ancient version of The pyromancer's
Guild in present day they're the ones who
eventually will create Wildfire I think the
idea is that the Valyrian pyromancers eventually
morphed into the pyromancer's guild and at some
point they just lost a lot of the knowledge
of ancient Valeria or it wasn't passed on or
it was destroyed during some big conflict we've
learned over time that a lot of prophecies a lot
of things wind up getting lost in rebellions and
insurrections viserys also says that they don't
have records of where the Valyrian dagger came
from before aegon came into possession of it
he probably got it from his father before him
but he does confirm that it came from ancient
valyria before that it sounds like what eventually
happened is that after he etched the prophecy on
it when he would tell the prophecy to each new
successor in the successor after that they would
pass the dagger along to each new king and I think
that's why viserys walks around everywhere with
the dagger on his belt so we're still many years
before the actual Conquest when aegon actually
had the dragon dream Westeros at that point was
full of many Petty Kings each ruling over their
seven different kingdoms each warring with each
other on the regular and aegon knew that unless
they all United under a single banner the realm
would never be able to stop the long night so he
decided the only way to achieve that would be if
he conquered the Seven Kingdoms and essentially
forced them to work together but remember he had
no idea when the long night would actually come
in none of his successors did either each one
thought that it could happen at any moment it
so in addition to all the infighting in the realm
that would happen across the many years across the
many Targaryen Kings you have to imagine each
one that knew about the prophecy was low grade
paranoid about that in the background on the house
of the dragon show in the trailers we've seen the
upgraded depiction of the famous map table it's
the same map table that Daenerys uses later in
Game of Thrones they just kind of reskinned it and
made it look a little bit cooler during House of
the Dragon but it's meant to be the exact same one
aegon is the one who created that table and he had
it done before he had the dragon dream so when he
was younger dealing with all the problems in the
century of blood he had taken his Dragon balloon
the black dread also flying all over Westeros so
we spent a lot of time visiting the main Realms
it was during this period that he had the map
table commissioned the actual war of Conquest
took about two years and then a little bit of
time after that before he was actually crowned
King of the six kingdoms in door and I'll talk
about that in a second too technically he did not
conquer Doran but after his Conquest they changed
the way the calendar works and they would refer
to dates before the conquest as BC in and after
Conquest as AC when he completed the conquest
he was crowned King by the high septon of that
day his crown was made of Valyrian steel it still
exists during the events of house the dragon like
the episodes we're watching they'll bring it
back eventually because it does play a role in
the episodes that are coming up everyone's always
talking about the Iron Throne that was made from
the melted swords of all the people during the war
of Conquest who refused to bend the knee he would
take his and his sister's dragons around to each
of the Seven Kingdoms in the different Realms and
demand that they bend the knee it's not clear if
he revealed the prophecy of the long night to each
of the seven different Realms when he was trying
to conquer them it sounds like he did not though
like the way that viserys talks about it it was
meant to be a secret that only each new successor
learned about and when aegon literally started
the war of conquest by flying his Dragon sailing
his troops from Dragonstone to the mainland
the place where he made landfall is at King's
Landing but at the time the area didn't have a
name they just called it aegon for it because
aegon turned the area into a small town for his
forces and built a small wooden fort there later
when he finished the war and was Crown King they
moved the capital to this area in aegon Fort and
renamed it King's Landing before that previously
for many many thousands of years back to the time
of the first men Old Town had always been the
biggest Port town so that was always viewed as
sort of like the unofficial capital of Westeros
the red keep that's become so famous the actual
city of King's Landing as you see it today like
the larger City didn't get built till many many
years later like maegor built the red keep so for
most of aegon's life he ruled from that smaller
Fort that they tore down to build the red keep
the most famous battles during the war of Conquest
were the burning of harrenhal the conquest of the
stormlands the conquest of the westerlands and the
reach and the invasion of Dorne there were only a
couple of Realms that actually bent the knee one
of his first engagements was the actual burning of
harrenhal so Harrenhal ruled over the riverlands
this area here at the time and it took about 40
years to build the castle paranol it's literally
the largest Castle in all of Westeros way bigger
than the red keep what wound up happening is that
the day that the castle was completed was also the
day a that aegon made landfall and when Harrenhal
refused to bend the knee aegon took blaring the
black dread melted the castle so that's why they
call it the burning of harrenhal in Forever
After People said that there was a curse on
harrenhal because each new Lord that would take
possession of the castle in these lands would
meet some untimely fate like they would die some
mysterious but gruesome death the latest being
Harwin strong and his father lyonel strong in that
same curse continues to the events of the Game of
Thrones series later in the timeline during the
conquest of the stormlands that actually led to
the creation of house Baratheon Orys Baratheon
the first member of their house was actually
aegon's bastard brother by his father so they
were actually good friends growing up and after
they conquered the stormlands he gave them to oras
Baratheon and basically named him Lord Baratheon
many years later into the events of the main
series The baratheons eventually intermarried with
the targaryens back and forth across the years so
for instance Robert Baratheon had Targaryen blood
in his veins through his grandmother who herself
was a legitimate full Targaryen so he actually
had a small claim came to the Iron Throne after
Robert's Rebellion which is why the realm were
so quick to support his claim to the Iron Throne
like oh well you're part Targaryen so you kind of
belong on the Iron Throne he would have been like
rhaegar's cousin one of the major battles against
the Lannisters of that day was called the Field
of Fire they did a version of that during Game of
Thrones season 7 where you see Daenerys basically
roast Jaime Lannister's loot train there wasn't an
actual battle aegon basically just took Balerion
in the black dread and burned a giant portion of
their army and then they bent the knee after that
the invasion of Dorne is important because during
aegon's Conquest it was unsuccessful he did not
conquer Doran it was until like way later in the
timeline even during the events of House of the
Dragon right now that we're watching Dorn has
not been conquered yet so it's still the six
kingdoms endoron during House of the Dragon
a few of the Realms that actually did bend the
knee it didn't require any real fighting at the
time were torrhen stark king of the north at the
time and sharra arryn ruler the veil at the time
and it's important to note that after the actual
war of conquest and after aegon was crowned that
wasn't the last war or battle that he fought in
the Seven Kingdoms the maesters recorded that
he and his sister vicenya and Rainey spent most
of the rest of their lives on their dragons or
going around the slow way putting down small
rebellions and dealing with each of the seven
different kingdoms so it wasn't like he conquered
Westeros and then it was all quiet in the realm
for hundreds of years later after aegon died he
would have passed the prophecy of A Song of Ice
and Fire to his son anes who then ruled and was
viewed by most as a weak King the realm weren't
huge fans of his because knowledge of the prophecy
was passed down from Jairus to viserys I'm also
assuming that maegor probably knew the prophecy
too because there was a lot of infighting in the
Battle of succession that took place when aenes
and maegor were alive so there were probably a
couple members in their family that knew the
prophecy at that time and then obviously we
covered the events of House of the Dragon the way
the showrunner explained their plan for covering
aegon's Conquest the blackfyre rebellions Tales of
Dunk and egg other major events in their family's
history from Fire and Blood is that they treat
the show like an anthology so like they have
three to four seasons planned for the dance of
the dragons and after that it'd be like season
five for instance they would do season 5 in it'd
be aegon's conquest and it'd be a completely new
cast in a new time period they cover aegon's
Conquest for a couple seasons and then they
do the same thing by jumping to a different
time period covering a different event so for
instance there might be like 10 to 12 seasons
of House of the Dragon but it'll cover several
different eras with different casts along the
way so for instance when they get to Robert's
Rebellion they would just call it house the
dragon Rebellion or something like that let
me know in the comments which time period do
you want them to cover after they're done with
the events of the dance of the dragons in a
couple Seasons my Full House of the Dragon
episode 7 video will post next on Sunday after
they release it be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my house the Dragon episode 7 video
I'll update the link as soon as I post that and
click here for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!